der krieg kommt quasi so die krippe hat
ein kleines grünes fältchen hat ein
bisschen fischer objektive perspektive
und das ist quasi die sicht eines
kriegers was die krippe hier grad macht
weiß ich nicht der partie relativ viel
spaß im wasser
allerdings ist das quasi sich eine
street was wir können einfach mit links
weg gehen und dann den wir im krieg drin
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft fakes heute wieder am dienstag
vorab erst mal ein paar kleine sachen
bevor es losgeht mit dem 5 mai kräftig
zwar ich habe mir gedacht ich mach jetzt
pro folge einfach immer fünf mal kräftig
das ist eine ganz coole sache und was
ich mir auch gedacht da letzter zeit
echt so viele fakes komme ich gar nicht
alle daran nehmen kann die mir gesendet
werden habe ich mir gedacht ich mache
jetzt pro woche zwei folgen also am
dienstag und am freitag kommen bei mir
immer die minecraft fakes das habe ich
bei twitter gefragt und ich habe gesagt
die sollen das retweeten wenn sie dafür
sind und favorisieren wenn sie dagegen
sind
das war so ein kleines auf und abbrennen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
das vital und adi in der bude kraft
sie sind von denen die sie das einfach
über die youtube abstimmen funktion mit
daumen hoch und daumen runter bestimmen
könnt also die beiden haben gesagt wenn
es wieder 20.000 bekommt dann führen die
die serie fort ich sag jetzt einfach
wenn dieses video 10.000 likes bekommt
dann gibt's pro woche zwei folgen weil
das zeigt mir dann halt einfach dass es
immer noch 10.000 leute gibt die das
ganze dann feiern wird und immer noch
10.000 leute die dann auch die zweite
folge pro woche anschauen würden und
wenn ihr sagt
damit schreibt mir einfach eure meinung
dazu warum es da eine folge sein sollte
weil mir macht das ganze spaß
es kommen richtig viele cool effect an
und ich würde sagen dass war die erste
sache die ich sagen wollte und die
zweite sache die ich ganz kurz
ansprechen wollte war in der letzten
folge habe ich eine kleine umfrage an
gemacht
so gemacht habe ich so eine kleine
umfrage erstellt und zwar habe das
geheimnisvolle geräusche was irgendwann
im video auftritt fortgesetzt werden
soll
ändert wurden 8000 stimmen abgegeben
4900 leute waren dafür und 3200 leute
waren dagegen also waren deutlich mehr
leute dafür also 61 prozent dafür 39
prozent dagegen
das heißt das geheimnisvolle geräusch
wird fortgesetzt irgendwann in dieser
folge wird dann irgendwann geräusch
auftauchen wo ihr mit allen die
kommentare spammen können welches
geräusch das war und dann will ich sagen
fangen wir jetzt auch schon mit den und
zwar habe ich mir hier schon eine
richtig coole neue minecraft 1.8 welt
runtergeladen ihr seht schon hier
eigentlich gar keine neuen blöcke aber
halt so ein paar sachen die hier auf
jeden fall hinzugefügt wurden
okay die ist nämlich nur wenn wir hier
noch ins menü gehen da sehen wir
beispielsweise den roten sandstein oder
die neuen press marien ziegel oder auch
hier bei denen ich hier so war das mit
dem ihr beispielsweise sachen wie das
genehmigen fällt chris martin kristalle
press marin schwere dinge wie
beispielsweise des kaninchens tonnen da
kann man kaninchen spawnen es wurden hat
richtig viele neue sachen hier
hinzugefügt die wir hier alle sehen
dazu kommt aber vielleicht noch ein 1.8
vorstellungsvideo ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich das mache weil das mega
lange dauern wird und für mich mehrere
stunden dann zu produzieren muss ich
schauen jedenfalls hat mir viel liebe zu
gesendet wenn man in der 1.8 gras
zerstört sie kennen das wenn wir jetzt
hier kaputt schlagen
so hatte da da da da da wir können es
hier kaputt schlagen blabla allerdings
dass ihr schon sehtest taucht immer ab
und zu seine kleine blume auf wenn wir
das ganze oben kaputt schlagen ist das
ganze nicht also wenn es oben kaputt
schlagen ist alles normal
allerdings hätte ich das ganze unten
kaputt schlagen seht ihr in ok dortmund
jetzt kommt nicht gesehen weil das
relativ kurz war
da ist ja keine blume aufgetaucht da ist
auch eine kleine blume aufgetaucht hier
auch okay da hat man wieder nicht
gewinnen kann
da war auch eine kleine blume da auch es
tauchen immer so kleine blümchen auf
wenn man so
gross gras unten kaputt schlägt und
danke auf jeden fall antike für den
effekt und jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
aufgefallen dass sich diese welt hier
die wir sonst eigentlich immer kern mit
den quads blöcken nicht mehr benutzen
sondern jetzt hier so eine normale
minecraft hält das habe ich einfach
gedacht weil ich dort immer ein anderes
terrain benutze immer meine andere
landschaft und das nicht immer alles so
gleich und ein würdig ist und es ist
eigentlich ganz cool und zwar ist es
ganz gut dass sich jetzt schon ein
bisschen wasser habe und zwar kennt ist
ähnlichen fall schieße dann wird er
immer langsamer und irgendwann breitet
er zum boden das team doch wenn ich
beispielsweise hier mal so ein fall hin
schieße wenn ich ihnen allerdings ins
wasser schießen sehen wir schon dass der
relativ steil untergeht ich werde das
ganze jetzt gleich mal versuchen so ein
bisschen darzustellen indem ich da jetzt
beispielsweise grabmal herangezoomt ab
jetzt werde ich da eben auch mal ran
suchen wir sehen der fall taucht relativ
schnell unter also ist sie einfach mal
so ein paar pfeile hintereinander
die tauchen relativ schnell unter also
die die fliegen eine normale
geschwindigkeit durchs wasser durch
dagegen die relativ schnell nach unten
ich mache das jetzt hier nochmal zack da
ist der fall geht nach unten wenn ich
stattdessen allerdings hier oben mal
schießen sehen wir der fall fliegt
normal bis zum ende und hier ist er
schon nach zehn blöcken oder weniger
geht er schon tief in die tiefen des
meeres und ist auf jeden fall cool danke
ein effekts für jan julia da kann dich
sie weiß nicht ob das nur in der 1.8 ist
oder auch in anderen versionen
allerdings wenn man im fallen ins wasser
schießt geht er halt relativ schnell 100
mhz es jetzt nicht so gut gesehen hier
die gründe sprechen aber ganz gut da
geht der fall relativ schneller und ich
finde am besten sieht man wenn man
selber im wasser stehen der fasan pfeil
schießt er geht der fall relativ schnell
da unten also im wasser kann man nur auf
ganz kurze distanz leute abschießen und
das war auf jeden fall fact nummer 2 der
dritte wurde mit zugesendet von helge
und zweimal die helge wie ich hab euch
ja schon in der letzten folge was er
letztlich glaube ich war es ist glaub
ich wähle ich glaube es war der letzten
folge habe ich euch das mit dem gamer 3
gezeigt also dass man beispielsweise
durch blöcke durch fliegen kann sich die
ganze landschaft angucken kann und ich
kann auf eine spinne beispielsweise
linksklick machen wir dann in der spinne
drin
das ganze kann ich auch bei einem
flipper machen ist ja auch ein mob und
beim flipper ist dann alles grün also
wenn ihr so in einen krieg rein geht der
kripo guckt quasi so der krippe hat dann
so ein kleines grünes fältchen hat ein
bisschen so eine fischer objektive
perspektive und das ist quasi die sicht
eines kriegers was der krippe hier
geraten
weiß ich nicht da hat ihn relativ viel
spaß im wasser allerdings ist das quasi
sich eine streetpass wir können einfach
mit links weg rein gehen und dann den
wir im krieg drin
also das ist ein ganz coole sache ich
hab's euch zu verletzten in der letzten
folge schon gezeigt allerdings dachte
ich dass das ganze noch mal aus der
sicht eines creepers auch sehr cool ist
und ich möchte hier auch nochmal mit dem
tintenfisch geht weiter tintenfisch
guckt nur wollen aber am
interessantesten ist es echt bei der
spinne die der zwei sichten hat und der
kripo der sonne grüne sicht hat und das
ganze ein bisschen komisch betrachtet
und ja das ist auf jeden fall die sich
das mit gametrailers effekt einmal drei
so mitten im video sind wir dann jetzt
auch bei einem geheimnisvollen geräusche
angekommen ich habe am anfang schon
gesagt die umfrage wurde
diesbezüglich fertig gestimmt dass die
leute gewonnen haben die das
weitergeführt haben weil mit dem
geheimnisvollen geräusch das heißt alle
dies nicht wollen tut mir leid wir haben
eine umfrage gemacht die leute haben
gewonnen ich würde sagen ich halte mich
jetzt meinem zukunft ein bisschen
schneller und ich würde sagen in der
letzten folge habe ich das nicht gemacht
mit dem geheimnisvollen gladbecker ins
gesagt weil er da die umfrage genannt
wurde aber dass dieses geheimnisvolle
geräusch für diese folge ist dass hier
was ist das für ein geheimnisvolles
geräusch gewesen schreibt wir uns in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns in der
nächsten folge wieder beziehungsweise
sehen wir uns einfach jetzt bei dem
affekt
wir kommen wir zum vierten feld und
wurde mit dieser effekt von simon raming
zugesendet wir kennen ja schon die
seelen blöcke wenn wir auf denen
rumlaufen sind wir relativ langsam
bewegen uns relativ langsam fort wenn
wir das gleiche allerdings bei den neu
hinzugefügt den zwei blöcken machen sind
wir noch langsamer also ich denke man
sieht schon wir sind viel viel langsamer
als bei den zwei blöcken
wir haben viel viel länger für diesen
weg gebraucht das ganze wackelt dann
immer noch so ein bisschen weil auf
diesem berg wenn man einmal springt es
ist ja quasi wie es am trampolin das
haben wir ein captain erfahren
allerdings sieht es so so schnell ist im
offside und so langsam ist man auf zwei
blöcken das heißt auf sand ist man noch
schneller als auf diesen zwei blöcken
also dieses line blöcke sind quasi der
blog auf dem man am langsamsten ist in
minecraft als wenn ich dann noch sinken
würden schwert in der hand halten würde
dann wäre es extrem krass langsam und
ich würde einfach sagen ja wir haben
einen neuen spitzenreiter beim block wo
man sich am langsamsten vor bewegt in
minecraft und das perfekt nur vier
kommen wir zu einer sache die ich über
die minecraft redet kommentare
vielleicht kennt ihr redet das ist so
ein
eine website wo man so ganz viele
kommentare zu einem thema abgeben kann
und das ganze quasi an gruppen sortiert
wird und zwar hab ich da herausgefunden
daher in minecraft jetzt rasend
hinzugefügt werden und eine person
meinte ja aber das ist total doof mein
hase jetzt aus damals also ja die nase
im bios genannt und er ist wohl
irgendwie abgehauen und der sie war sehr
traurig darüber
und der sah so schwarz-weiß aus und
normalerweise wenn man herzens bond
kommen relativ selten diese schwarz
weißen hatten damit zum beispiel
eingesehen und wenn wir beispielsweise
mal einen amboss hinsetzen und dieses
verschaffe kaninchens post nennen
dann haben wir hier dann kommt ihre die
thorsten dann haben die alle die gleiche
sehen die alle gleich aus und das ist
eine spezielle textur die sieht so ein
bisschen anders aus wir wissen noch hier
ist dieser normale hase der
schwarz-weiße und das hier sind jetzt
diese post hasen und die sehen so aus
wie diese abgehobenen hasen von dem
reddot user häufig das könnt ihr einfach
mal bei google eingeben minecraft rapid-
tost also einfach das hier
minecraft rabbit toast oder halt im wiki
nachlesen es auch noch mal erklärt dass
die ganzen in die entwickler haben sich
so gedacht so ja bla bla
wenn man post macht dann ist es halt so
ein kleines tribut an diesen ganzen
hätten
an diese personen die da ihren hasen
damals verloren hat und die testphase
sind quasi alle gleich es ist so ein
bisschen ähnlich wie wenn man
beispielsweise ein schaf dinner benennt
was ich auch schon mal vorgestellt habe
dass es dann so regenbogenfarben ist und
ja das ist der fünfte effekt die sonne
geht passend unter ich würde sagen das
war's mit dieser minecraft folge
vielleicht habt ihr das geheimnisvolle
geräusche erraten wie gesagt wenn ihr
zwei folgen pro woche wollte also wenn
ihr zb bis freitag noch eine effektvolle
kommt dann gibt einen daumen hoch ab und
sind mit 10.000 daumen hoch erreicht
sind dann weiß ich dass wenigstens noch
10.000 leute das ganze feiern würden der
youtube dann springt die kunden die
internet und ja wenn ihr das wollt dann
gebt einfach den daumen hoch deshalb
nichts mit mitleid geilheit zu tun
daumen hoch bedeutet gar nichts mehr bei
videos mittlerweile sondern das ist
einfach nur seine abstimmung weil ich
kein bock habt das wieder übrigen bei
ihnen eine website zu machen und viele
konnten da eigentlich abstimmen weil die
cookies blockiert wurden und alles also
eine ganz einfache abstimmung zart dann
macht es einfach und dann liegt der
eigentlich bedanke mich fürs zuschauen
deshalb wieder sehr viel spaß macht e
mail die in der beschreibung konnte
gmail.com ich kann nicht dafür
garantieren dass in die ganze sache noch
nicht kennt wen denn demnächst mal
wieder dran das gewünscht habe